[MUSIC PLAYING]
REUVEN LAX: My
name is Reuven Lax.
I'm a software engineer
on Google Cloud Platform,
and we're here with
our wonderful partners
at Scotiabank to talk about
Google Cloud Dataflow streaming
and how we autoscale
streaming pipelines.
And then we will talk
about how Scotiabank
uses this functionality.
So first, a little bit of
background on streaming
Dataflow pipelines and
streaming pipelines in general,
and why autoscaling
is important.
So unlike traditional
batch applications
where you just run
once and then they're
done, if later, you have
more data, you run it again
with a larger set of
inputs and more resources,
streaming pipelines
are always on.
You usually start a streaming
cluster, a streaming pipeline,
and just leave it
running continuously.
But in most cases, the incoming
load to the streaming pipeline
varies over time.
Often, these are daily
diurnal variations.
So at midnight, you have much
lower levels of data coming in,
then at peak hours,
your volume increases
and keeps going up and
down throughout the day.
And so traditionally,
what people
have had to do to deal
with this is to provision
their streaming pipelines
for the peak load--
figure out how
many resources do I
need to handle the
busiest time of day,
make sure my
streaming pipeline has
at least that many resources--
sometimes even more because
if anything falls behind,
you need to process even
faster than that to catch up.
And this is very expensive.
You're wasting many
of your resources
throughout most of the
day, and one of the things
we set out to solve with
Dataflow's streaming
autoscaling.
So here's a quick
agenda for this talk.
I'm going to start off with a
quick overview of Apache Beam
and Dataflow, and how we
execute streaming pipelines.
I'm going to talk a bit about
what our primary signals are
for streaming autoscaling,
and how this works today
and in our new, upcoming
streaming engine, which
will replace the current one.
And then finally, our
representative from Scotiabank
will talk about how they are
using Dataflow and autoscaling
to solve their problems.
So here we have a visual of
essentially the Hello, World
of data processing problems.
So the Hello, World of
data processing problem
that everybody likes to
start with is count words.
Reading a bunch of lines and
output how many words you have.
It's a fairly trivial
problem, but it's
the Getting Started guide
that everybody uses.
So on the right,
this is the code
you would write
with the Apache Beam
API, which is the API to
Dataflow to count words.
This is a streamed
pipeline, so we
read words for
our Pub/Sub topic,
split every line into
its component words.
And here we've decided to
window it by five minutes.
So our output is
every five minutes,
how many of each
unique words did we
see in that last five minutes?
And then finally, count
them and write the data out.
Now, it turns out that even
though this pipeline has
one, two, three, four,
five steps in it,
Dataflow has an optimizer that
optimizes this into a smaller
number of steps for execution.
And what we actually end up
with is two steps separated
by, actually, the
component of this count,
where we have to
shuffle data around,
so we can actually count
the words properly.
And that is the
streaming shuffle
on the left connecting
the two steps.
And it turns out that when
it comes to autoscaling,
we can usually look
at these two steps
independently and autoscale
each one separately.
And also, unlike
batched pipelines,
where you will have
steps in a sequence,
and usually one step
finishes completely,
and then when it's
done, the next step
starts, in a streaming pipeline
where data is constantly
streaming through, all
steps in the pipeline
are active at the same time.
So your autoscaling
algorithms must
take into account
everything in parallel.
So how do I turn on autoscaling?
Well, today, you turn it
on by passing in a flag
to your pipeline when
you launch it and say
autoscalingAlgorithm=THROUGHPUT
BASED.
In the future, we
plan for autoscaling
to just be the default--
always on.
But until then, this
is how you turn it
on for streaming pipelines.
And you can also specify
a max num workers
flag, which will give us
a ceiling on autoscaling.
So if you say max num
workers equals 1,000,
then we will never
autoscale up above 1,000,
even if it needs it to
keep up with its input.
So how does this work
under the covers?
So to explain a little bit
about how our autoscaling works,
I have to start
off by explaining
a little bit about
Dataflow's execution model
under the covers--
how we take a Dataflow program
and actually schedule it
and run it on GCE workers.
And the first thing
I have to explain
is that in Dataflow,
our underlying runner,
everything is done in
the context of a key.
So all data is really
separated into key value pairs
that we then shuffle
around and process.
If you've done a group
by key or account
by key, or in this case, account
words, then the key is obvious.
The key is just the
word you're counting.
If you were not doing
any sort of aggregation,
it turns out we still have a
key that we just randomly assign
to all the elements.
We take all the keys.
We then prefix each
one with a hash.
So we take a hexadecimal
hash of each key
and put it at the beginning
of every key, which
does two things.
First of all, it
smears out the work.
So if you have a lot of
keys that are very similar,
they don't end up together.
It tends to spread them
out across the hash space.
And it also gives us a nice
way of chopping this work up.
Since every key starts
with a 16 character hash,
we can then just take
ranges of these hashes
and use that to divide up the
work into multiple charts.
So here is an example of
Stage A. We have taken
all the keys, based off of
an estimate of how large we
think the input is.
We have divided
the key ranges up
into a certain number of ranges
and started the pipeline.
So next, we actually
start the workers
that will run these stages
in the streaming pipeline.
So here, these little blue
icons, our standard GCE icon.
We started up a
number of GCE workers.
And for each GCE worker, we take
some number of these key ranges
and assign it to that worker.
So here, we have KRI or KRJ
are assigned to this one.
KRX, KRY are assigned
to that worker.
There are more
workers in between.
Every worker has some number of
key ranges for this streaming
pipeline assigned.
Now, how does this actually
work on our system today?
And this is something
that I'll explain
later is changing with the
upcoming streaming engine.
But the way the
current system works
is everything runs on
these GCE virtual machines.
So every virtual machine
that has a key range assigned
has persistent disks
attached to it to store state
for that key range.
So if you're doing a
five minute aggregation
or a one hour
windowed aggregation,
you need to be able
to constantly keep
track, persistently, of
what your aggregations are
so far for this window.
If the worker crashes
and has to restart,
you don't want to lose any data.
So currently, we use
persistent disk and a key value
store on top of the
persistent disk on each VM
to store the state.
They'll explain later we have--
our new streaming engine moves
all of this into the Cloud,
and so all this work
moves off these workers.
You also need to shuffle data.
So Pub/Sub is a completely
unordered, unsorted source,
which means if I'm
counting words,
all the words might show
up on all the workers.
So if I want to take the
word next for instance,
and count how many nexts
I've seen over the past five
minutes, I need to make sure
all these next counts end up
on a unique worker so
I can do this count.
So we have a streaming
shuffle system
that moves these records
around between the workers
so we can do these counts.
So now that I've talked a
little bit about how things work
under the covers, let's move
on to autoscaling for a second,
or for the rest of my talk.
In order to scale a
pipeline, we need signals.
We need something that tells
us this pipeline doesn't have
enough workers attached to it.
We're not keeping up.
And also a signal that gives us
an estimate of how many workers
we need in this pipeline.
Your pipeline is not keeping up.
You have 15 workers.
I estimate that with 25 workers
you'll be able to keep up.
So what are our primary
signals for autoscaling?
The first one is backlog.
Is there data coming in?
If data is coming in faster
than we can process it,
then the data is going to start
piling up and form a backlog.
So if this backlog is high,
and especially if this backlog
keeps growing,
that's a sign that we
don't have enough workers
and we need to autoscale up.
The second one is throughput.
How fast am I currently
processing the data?
Maybe I'm currently
processing the data
at 10,000 QPS, 100,000
QPS, or a million QPS.
But then we have to contrast
that with the actual input
rate.
So the input rate is how
fast the data is actually
showing up at my pipeline.
So if I'm processing
data a million QPS,
and my input rate
is 1.2 billion QPS,
clearly I'm not
processing fast enough.
And the input rate--
we can always estimate
the input rate
by taking the throughput that
we're currently processing data
at, and then measuring how
fast is our backlog growing?
So if I'm processing data at,
say, 10 gigabytes per second,
but then I can
measure my backlog
and say, OK, but
my backlog keeps
growing at 1
gigabyte per second,
a good estimate
of your input rate
is 11 gigabytes per second.
If I was able to process that,
my backlog would stop growing.
And finally, we look
at CPU consumption
to understand how much CPU
all these workers are using,
which is another important
signal for autoscaling.
So let's talk for a
second about backlog.
So here we have Cloud Pub/Sub.
So a bunch of data
coming from Cloud
Pub/Sub into our pipeline.
Presumably, there is
a publisher out there
that is pushing data
into Cloud Pub/Sub.
And remember, we had two stages
in this pipeline, stage A
and stage B. Stage
A is a stage that's
pulling data from Pub/Sub.
So the first thing
we want to measure
is what is the
backlog for stage A?
If you're familiar with
Google Cloud Pub/Sub,
Google Cloud Pub/Sub will
store a backlog for you.
In fact, it will store up to
seven days worth of backlog.
This can happen if data is
getting pushed to Pub/Sub
and nobody's pulling
from it, or if data
is getting pushed to
Pub/Sub and you're
pulling from Pub/Sub slower than
the publishers are publishing.
So the first thing we
do for stage A is we
say, OK, our source is Pub/Sub.
Let's ask Google Cloud Pub/Sub
what the current backlog is.
So we have an internal API
that gives us the backlog.
It's also available
through Stackdriver.
So you can go to Stackdriver
yourself and look
at the unacked messages
metrics and see
what the signal is
that we're looking at
to know that the backlog
is building up in Pub/Sub
and faster than
we're draining it.
But then remember we have a
streaming shuffle between stage
A and stage B. Stage B is where
we produce the final counts--
the final windowed
counts for these words.
So we need to measure the
backlog between stage A and B
as well.
So if we're pulling
data from Pub/Sub,
and we're keeping
up from Pub/Sub,
and then we're pushing
data to this next stage
and say, hey, count words, and
the next stage can't keep up,
the backlog for that next
stage will grow as well.
So that also means we don't
have enough workers running
to maintain our pipeline.
So the first backlog
tells us we don't
have enough workers running to
pull from Pub/Sub fast enough.
The second backlog tells us
we don't have enough workers
internally to do all these
counts we're trying to do.
In this talk, I'm going to make
a few simplifying assumptions
to make the autoscaling
algorithm a little bit simpler.
So the first assumption
is that every stage
can be sized independently.
That I can look at every
stage in my pipeline,
decide what the appropriate
number of workers
is for that stage,
and then I can
decide, based off of all
that, how many workers I need
for my entire pipeline.
Maybe I take the max of all
those and say that's how many
workers I need.
I'm assuming that the load
is distributed fairly evenly
between workers.
So if you remember,
I said that we
put a hash, a prefix
on all the keys.
This actually does
a fairly good job
of distributing load fairly
evenly among all workers.
And finally, in practice,
we apply smoothing.
So as I'll explain
in a minute, there's
some cost to autoscaling.
So if you have a sudden
spike that lasts a second,
you don't necessarily
want your autoscaling
to be like, up, down, up,
down, up, down, up, down.
So we apply a smoothing window,
which currently is in practice,
I believe a two minute
smoothing window.
So we have some sort of smoother
autoscaling up and down.
So this means that autoscaling
works fairly well when you have
continuous variations in load.
If your problem is my
load is usually 10 QPS,
and then once an hour
it spikes to a million
QPS for five
seconds, autoscaling
is going to take some time to
go up and down for that spike.
So how do we use these
signals to actually decide
we need to autoscale up?
Well, when the backlog
is high or when
we see the backlog is growing,
which is a sure sign that we
don't have enough resources
to run this pipeline,
we start generating
size recommendations.
And we have the Dataflow
service and our backend
has a loop that is constantly
generating size recommendations
for our pipeline.
So what is a size
recommendation?
Well, first of all, we
measure the input rate.
And if you remember,
the input rate
is the rate we're
currently processing
at plus the rate at which
the backlog for the pipeline
is increasing.
And that's the estimate of
how fast the data is really
arriving.
After we've measured
the input rate,
it turns out we're
not quite done.
Because if my
backlog is currently
1 terabyte, and I upscale until
I can handle the current input
rate of data, my backlog will
just stay frozen at 1 terabyte.
Because I now have
enough workers
to handle the data
as it's coming in,
but not enough workers
to drain that backlog.
So we then have to
add to that, how many
workers do I need to
consume that backlog quickly
while maintaining the
current input rate?
Then eventually we
will drain that backlog
and be at a backlog of
zero or close to zero.
And at that point, all
we need is enough workers
to keep up with the input rate.
And as I just mentioned, we
average this recommendation
over a sliding
two minute window.
So we have a little
bit of smoothing
on these recommendations.
So what do we do when the
estimated backlog is low?
So how do we decide that
we have too many workers
and we can now
downscale this job?
Well, I'll divide it
into the current world
and the new streaming engine
world, which is actually
in beta and can be tried now.
The current world takes
a new recommendation,
but actually has to be very
conservative in downscaling.
And the reason why
is, if you remember,
the current architecture
attaches persistent disks
to every worker.
And the work key ranges are
tied to these persistent disks.
Empirically, we found that
if you get an imbalance--
so you start having
like 10 persistent disks
on this worker, and 2 persistent
disks on this worker--
it actually makes
performance worse,
because the workers
with a very small number
of persistent disks
become a bottleneck
for all the other workers.
So on the persistent
disk architecture,
we attempt to only downscale
if we can make sure
that all the workers
have an even number
of persistent disks, which often
means that if we can downscale
by one VM, we might
hold off and say
that'll create an imbalance.
We're going to wait until we can
downscale by enough VMs to even
out the persistent disks.
And only then will we downscale.
On streaming engine,
our new architecture,
there are no persistent
disks attached to the VMs.
The VMs are stateless.
So we can download continuously.
So we could just
monitor the CPU.
We target downscaling a
CPU utilization of 80%.
So you do not want
to target 100% CPU
utilization, because
that does not
give you enough wiggle room.
So often you might
have small spikes
that are not high enough
to trigger upscaling
or not long enough
to trigger upscaling.
You want to actually have
enough wiggle room handle
small variations in input.
So this is what our
worker instance looks
like in the current world.
So this is a GCVM.
We run the SDK worker.
This is the Dataflow or a Beam
code that you have written.
So this is a Java or
a Python process that
runs the dataflow pipeline.
There is another process
that runs on this VM that
is our streaming engine worker.
This is the process
that knows how
to interpret the
code you've written
and turn it into persistent
shuffle and so on.
And then there are a number
of persistent disks attached
to these workers.
This is the world
we're moving to.
So the new world,
all of the GC workers
are completely stateless.
There is no persistent
disk attached
to them, which means we can
just add more or tear them down
as we want.
There is less cost associated.
It's less complex, so we don't
have to detach disks, move them
to another VM and attach them.
And we also do no longer
have this restriction
of trying to keep an
even number of disks
attached to each worker, because
there are no disks to attach.
In this world, the
Dataflow service
and the streaming engine
service both in the cloud.
And all the state storage and
all the timers and so on also
run in the cloud.
Which, as a side
note, something I
forgot to mention earlier when
I was talking about streaming
signals, we actually have
one more streaming signal.
The way windowing
works in Dataflow
is under the covers our
streaming engine has
a notion of timers, where for
every key we're processing,
it can set timers at the
end of the current window.
And when the window expires,
all these timers fire.
And when the timers fire,
we say, OK, the window
is done for this key.
Process the counter
and spit it out.
We can measure timer backlog.
So we can measure that a lot
of timers are about to fire.
What this means practically
is our autoscaling
can see the future in a way.
We can detect that, hey, their
input rate is still steady,
but we're about to hit
the end of a window,
and all of these timers
are about to fire.
We better start
autoscaling now so we
don't hit the end of the
window and then suddenly start
thrashing, and wait two minutes,
and then start autoscaling up.
So this allows window processing
to autoscale much more smoothly
by being able to use timers
as one of our signals.
And as I said, no persistent
disk, key ranges are fluid.
This is in beta.
So you can try this
today on your pipeline.
It is currently only launched in
beta right now in two regions.
So right now, US central one
and Europe West one I believe
are the two regions where
we've launched this in.
But in one of those
two regions, you
can pass in this
experimental flag,
and it will run on
the new beta engine.
And if you have any issues
running this engine,
please let us know immediately.
This is why things are on
beta so we could shake out
all problems with the service
before we launch it to GA.
So there's some
cost to resizing.
So in the persistent
disk world, the cost is--
there's latency detaching
and moving disks around
and reattaching them.
There's some startup latency
for a virtual machine.
We have to pause work while
the rebalance is in process.
You had a worker.
You have to move some work from
another work to the new one.
And for all these reasons,
after a resizing event,
you need a stabilization window.
So what you don't want
is a hysteresis problem
where I resize and
move work around,
and that temporarily slows
things down slightly,
and that makes me think that I'm
falling more behind so I scale
up more and scale up more.
You can have a positive feedback
loop that goes out of control.
So after a resizing
event, instead,
we introduce a
stabilization period
to make sure the system can
quiet down after a resize
before we examine it again
and decide to resize again.
The hope is that our initial
estimate on the resize
was accurate so we won't
have to resize again quickly.
But if we do, we need
to wait slightly longer
before doing so.
And finally, low CPU
with high backlog.
There are cases in which
the backlog keeps going up.
We start adding more
workers, adding more workers.
And then we look at the workers
and say all these worker,
none of these VMs are
using more than 10% of CPU.
All this autoscaling
up is not helping.
And the reason why could
be that maybe your pipeline
is talking to external service
and you're being throttled.
So adding more workers
is not helping matters.
It might be making matters
worse because you're just
hammering that external
service even more.
And it's going to start
throttling you more.
Could also be due to
a bug in a pipeline.
Maybe your pipeline is
throwing an exception.
And so that's why it's
not making progress.
We're not helping matters
by adding more workers.
So more workers can throw
exceptions in parallel.
So for this reason, we
actually have a CPU cap.
If the CPU is too low,
we stop upscaling.
So I mentioned Cloud Pub/Sub.
So Cloud Pub/Sub is
natively supported
by our streaming engine.
And there is an API--
currently an
internal API that we
use to measure the
backlog and the watermark
for Cloud Pub/Sub.
Although this backlog API is
also available via Stackdriver.
You can go to
Stackdriver and add
an [INAUDIBLE] enact metric
to monitor the backlog
for your Pub/Sub topic.
The Beam SDK also
supports custom sources.
So if you have a
custom source, you
have to implement these
two methods, which
allow you to report what the
current backlog of your custom
source is.
And we can use that
to estimate backlog
on the source and upscale.
If you have a source that
doesn't report those,
upscaling will still happen
based off our internal backlog
measurement, but it will not
work as well because we cannot
measure what the actual
backlog on the source is.
And Pub/Sub, which
I already mentioned,
our Kafka source and
our Kinesis source
support this out of the box.
So if you use either
Kafka or Kinesis,
backlog will be measured.
So in conclusion, I talked
about our primary signals
for autoscaling, a bit
about how our Java SDK is
supported for autoscaling.
Python streaming, which
is currently in beta,
will be supporting
autoscaling very, very soon.
And the new streaming engine,
which is currently in beta,
will take our
existing autoscaling
and make it work
that much better.
And now I'm delighted
to introduce
Roy Bryant from Scotiabank.
Scotiabank has been
one of the leaders
in the financial services
industry of moving
their processing over to
Google Cloud Platform,
especially this type
of data processing.
And Roy is here to
tell us a little bit
about what they've done
and how they've done it.
[APPLAUSE]
ROY BRYANT: Thanks, Reuven.
Yeah, so I'm going to bring it
up a little bit higher level.
Reuven's been talking about the
details of how Dataflow works.
And I'm just going to
talk a bit about the use
cases we're using.
We're trying to
transform the bank.
Pub/Sub and Dataflow are
foundational to that.
So I just want to talk a
bit about what we're doing.
A little bit about
Scotiabank, in case you
don't know anything about it.
The bank's been
around a long time.
It's in the top 40 or 25
largest banks in the world,
depending on how
you measure that.
It's really international.
It was founded in
Nova Scotia long ago,
and doing trade that
came into the port.
So more than half the
business is outside Canada.
There is business
in 55 countries,
23 million customers,
which is getting
close to the
population of Canada.
And so we've got
a few challenges
in the infrastructure.
Part of it is it's been
around a long time.
So we have legacy backend
systems more than 50 years old.
We're doing lots of digital
banking and transformation,
online stuff in many
regions, many countries.
So we want to go fast there.
We've also done a
lot of acquisitions.
So over one 10-year period,
we acquired 30 banks,
each with two data centers.
So we have lots of data centers.
And sort of this effort
to consolidate that
and rationalize the stacks.
So we've got some complexity.
So the trust and
the reputation is
foundational to
the business, as it
is with the financial services
across financial services.
And how we handle
PII is key to that.
So big step is moving
the PII to the cloud
and making sure
that's entirely safe.
And we've got a lot of
stakeholders, security
and operations, as every
large organization does.
We also have, in
addition to legal,
we've got internal and external
auditing, we've got regulators,
and we're in 55 countries.
So we've got 55 regulators.
And there's a tension about
the velocity for the digital.
We want to go fast and
iterate and get features out
to customers moving agile.
And then we also have a lot of
backend infrastructure teams
that we care a lot about
stability and reliability
and everything.
We actually want both places.
We want the digital stuff
to be stable and reliable,
and we want to bring more
velocity to the core banking
systems.
So we're trying to
do that using cloud.
When we think about cloud,
we're thinking about it
more as a method rather
than a destination.
So we conflate cloud as
moving it to cloud along
with DevOps and CICD and
test-driven development and all
those pieces.
So we've got two
production systems that
are using Pub/Sub and Dataflow.
First one I'll talk about
is our log streaming.
So we've got pulling in
structured and unstructured
data and logs from Stackdriver
from many different sources,
from all of the
projects running.
And then we publish
those to Pub/Sub.
And then use Dataflow to
route those to secure SEC Ops
and persist them for regulatory
purposes, feed it back to Ops,
all that kind of thing.
And for this, we
found it works--
Pub/Sub and Dataflow work
well, and they're performant,
and they give us the
performance we need.
And we don't really see any
issue with that going forward.
So we're happy with it.
This isn't really
transformational.
The second use case I
think is more interesting
because it's the
foundation for how
we're transforming the bank.
So the problem we're
trying to solve
is we've got a lot of
different backend systems
with many data sources.
So in Canadian banking, we've
got over 2,000 production
databases, all with data
in different formats
and different
representations, no agreement
on what a customer is and what
a first name of a customer is,
and what an account
is and so forth.
So we're trying to
rationalize that.
So it's the 2,000 in Canada.
And we're in 55 countries.
We're not going to in-place
just start refactoring
all our databases.
It's just not going to work.
So what we're doing
is we're using cloud
as an opportunity to restructure
the way we do all this.
So on ingestion, we're
transforming the data
into a standard format.
So we've got an enterprise data
model and a business glossary
that you can define what
exactly is a customer.
What is a customer's first name?
And then we map from
local schemas in all
the different data sources.
We bring that in.
We map it to the
standard schema,
say this is the
customer's first name.
This is an account
number, all that.
Bring the data all
into one place.
That does a bunch of things.
One is that it opens the
door for doing analytics.
And you can do analytics
across many data
sources, all the performance,
and so forth from that.
The other thing is that it puts
a cache of the data in cloud.
So we do a bunch of
Canadian banking.
And you're using your
handset and you're
doing online banking.
And then we've got
backends in Toronto.
We've got backends in Chile.
Everything's far apart.
So what we're doing
is we're taking
a cache of things in
cloud so we can put
the compute close to the data.
So we're calling
this the event layer.
This event layer,
there's two pieces
that Pub/Sub and
Dataflow are key in.
One is the ingesting the
data into the common format.
So for here, we're streaming
from backend systems.
And it's MQ, COBOL copybook,
whatever, down there.
Transform that.
Stream that up into cloud.
It comes into Pub/Sub.
And then we use Dataflow.
So on ingestion,
we're transforming it
to the standard schema.
We're also using DLP and
KMS in tokenizing the data.
So we've got it in flight.
Comes in.
And then in Dataflow, call DLP
on the fly as it flows through.
Tokenize that.
Land it in Spanner.
Now it's all
encrypted, safe there.
And then we just lock down
re-identification separately.
So there's the standard
format, getting the cache.
The other piece is
moving to event driven.
So we're taking
events that can be
infrastructure events or
security or operations,
also just changes
in backend data.
We're detecting that,
raising an event for that.
Or a transaction
comes in and then
we're persisting
the transactions.
So now instead of
the application
needing to figure out how to
talk to many backend systems
and having the business
logic in the application
and in the backend
systems, and the APIs,
and APIs call other APIs,
and it is really hard
to tell what the
business logic is.
So instead, about changing
it to the event flow.
And then that gives us
all the data in the cloud.
And then when we
start looking forward,
we can see what are the
changes in the backend system.
So if we can understand
the data and we build up
a history of exactly how
the data changes on events,
we can start reversing
out and making sure
that we've got the
business logic right.
So if we're trying to replace a
backend system, we can run it.
We've got some code that we
assert works the same way.
You can run it through all
the last year's transactions
and see if you get the
same answer every time.
And then for the APIs, we don't
want all these layered APIs
on the backend systems.
So what we do is we bring the
data into the event layer.
So applications can
either subscribe
to the stream of events and
see transactions that way,
or could query the storage.
Or we also expose
it through APIs.
So we have a data
as a service API
that lets you
access API driven--
do the queries against the data.
And then we have a
bank as an API level
above that with bank concepts.
You can say, what
are the accounts
that this customer has?
And then it will use the data
APIs, it can do the queries.
Give a structured
way to get at that.
So what we've accomplished.
So we have these couple
of things in production.
And as I said,
the transformation
to standardized data
and event driven
is really foundational
to our strategy
for transforming the bank.
And then Pub/Sub
and Dataflow are
foundational to
the implementation
of that strategy.
And we've been really happy
with the performance, the cost,
reliability of the systems.
They've all worked really
well in production.
The other factor we considered
in choosing Google to do this
is there's a really
strong relationship,
a collaborative relationship.
And we got a lot of
engineering support.
So it's gone really well.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]